[Musique]
les marins shadoks perdues dont le
cosmos ont vu quelque chose au bout de
l'infini et qu'ils prennent pour la
planète jbe mais il faut savoir qu'en ce
temps-là le cosmos n'était pas tellement
infinie que ça il n'était d'ailleurs pas
infinies du tout et pour tout dire il
était plutôt rond de sorte que quand on
partait d'un endroit et en allant tout
droit au bout d'un certain temps on ira
arrivait pour aller quelque part en
général le plus simple était encore de
partir de là nous on voulait aller et
avec du temps et un peu de chance on y
arrive est effectivement mais les
shadows que n'était pas au courant de
tout ça et au prix d'incroyables
sacrifices ces malheureuses bêtes allait
arriver là d'où il était parti c'était
leur planète qu'il prenait pour la
planète jbe avec d'infinies précautions
il débarque nuitamment chez eux pour
s'emparer de leurs fusées ils la
transporte en catimini sur leur bateau
et repartent comme ils sont venus mais
en sens contraire évidemment le lot
demain matin les shadoks qui venait
comme d'habitude en faire de nouveaux
essais de fusil sur d'abord étonné puis
ils criaient victoire victoire note
refusé marchand fat et les parties elles
mêmes partait tout seul
la seule chose que ces pauvres bêtes
avaient oublié malheureusement c'était
une montée de dos
[Musique]